suppose you're digging through your
grandma's attic and come across a
mysterious locked suitcase grandma tells
you that the key for the suitcase is
probably in this other box this box
contains more boxes with more boxes
inside those boxes the key is in a box
somewhere
what's your algorithm to search for the
key in this unit you'll learn about
recursion recursion is used in many
algorithms and is a building block for
understanding later units in this course
recursion can be used to solve the
previous problem of searching for a key
in nested boxes you will also learn to
break down a problem into a base case
and a recursive case I will be showing
you a lot of code examples I highly
recommend trying to run the code for
yourself also at least once you should
try to step through a recursive function
with pen and paper to get a better sense
of how recursive functions work this
unit also includes a lot of pseudocode
studio code is a high-level description
of the problem you're trying to solve in
code it's written like code but it's
meant to be closer to human speech let's
get back to searching for a key in a box
that contains boxes which contain other
boxes first I'll show you a method to
solve this problem that uses while loops
then I'll show you a method that uses
recursion here's the first method 1 make
a pile boxes to look through 2 while the
pile is empty grab a box and look
through it 3 if you find a key you're
done for if you find a box add it to the
pile of boxes to look through later 5
repeat here's the second method 1 look
through the box 2 if you find a key
you're done 3 if you find a box go to
step 1 which approach seems easier to
you the first way uses a while
here's the first method using pseudocode
first we make a pile of boxes to look
through from the boxes in the main box
while the pile is not empty choose a box
to look through for each item in the box
check if the item is another box if it
is another box append or add it to the
pile boxes we still have to look through
if the item we found is a key then yell
- everyone excitedly found the key
keep checking the boxes until the pile
is empty
the second way uses recursion recursion
is where a function calls itself here's
the second way in pseudocode first we
check the box passed into the function
and go through each item in the box if
the item is a box then we pass the box
into the function again if the item is a
key then yell - everyone excitedly found
the key both approaches accomplish the
same thing but the second approach seems
cleaner a recursion is used when it
makes the solution clearer there's
actually no performance benefit to using
recursion in fact loops are sometimes
better for performance however people
still use recursion since it often makes
code easier to understand and look
cleaner many important algorithms use
recursion so it's important to
understand
because a recursive function calls
itself it's easy to write a function
incorrectly that ends up in an infinite
loop for example suppose you want to
write a function that prints a countdown
you could write it recursively like this
however if you run this code there's a
problem the function will run forever if
your code is in an infinite loop press
control-c to kill the script when you
write a recursive function you have to
tell it when to stop rehearsing that's
why every recursive function has two
parts the base case and the recursive
case the RISC cursive case is when the
function calls itself the base case is
when the function doesn't call itself
again so it doesn't go into an infinite
loop here is the function from before
with the addition of a base case the if
I is less than or equal to 1 is the base
case that is when the function will not
call itself anymore in the else section
is the recursive case that is what will
keep happening if the base case has not
yet been reached so unlike the last
example this function will actually end